thanks to all your requests today we are
testing everyone's favorite little
action camera oh the GoPro this buddies
go so good
welcome to Battle Damage
the GoPro Hero introduced in 2004 is a
favorite of extreme sports enthusiasts
everywhere but we've got something
special in store for it everyone knows
how tough a GoPro is inside of its
trusty armor but today we're going to
test it naked that's right we're going
to drop it from a normal height naked
from really high naked and finally we're
going to test its extreme limits make it
super naked these things are tough I
need to be fine
roll action
what's fine an egg so recording still
recording boring you're driving from
higher all right with shifting feet up
I'm sure looks crazy hi from the GoPro
angle roll action there's like I've
never seen this before this like a
little motorcycle picture and then a
question mark and then it waited for a
second then the question mark turned to
okay that turns on does it record yeah
hello test record for our third and
final test we're going to see what it's
like to be a golf ball as our naked
GoPro takes on a 9-iron roll
it just like completely vaporized I just
see like grommets and stuff oh here we
go here's the main carcass over here
this is half of it do you have the other
half
yeah I think so where's the card though
there's pieces over here Oh found it
yeah yeah it's totally attacked I mean
he looks fine then at least no matter
what happens in your GoPro stunt work
you're going to have your card
thanks for watching everyone remember
let us know which ones to battle test
next down there in the comments or on
social media with the hashtag battle
damage the things I do for science
steady